have you guys seen this clip going
around Twitter I'm gonna pause this real
quick this one you guys have seen this
bike it's problem yeah it's the guy he's
on punching the back of a seat what's
going on here Brian this guy's on the
seat where that does not recline near
the back and then she's reclining into
him and he's punching her seat like you
know it's rude to proclaim into me when
I can't become but when I can't recline
back myself so a lot of people are
divided some people think he's an
[ __ ] for punching her seat and some
people think that she's an [ __ ] for
reclining the seat well she has rights
per class dude she brought up a client
see number one number two so she paid
her money number two three you're not
allowed to do that you're harassing so
she's your your your your you're
actually being unlawful there are rules
against that your you're physically
essentially physically harassing whether
it's assaulting odds different story but
that's definitely physical harassment
yeah you know so he's a piece of
douchebag I would never do that I'd be
like this is my shitty seat you move
back you you you know you've a client I
says what maybe you could ask hey do you
mind I'm my I have no room do you mind
not doing that apparently he did ask
cool moments before he actually it was
the part in the flight where they had
food out and so he asked oh can you put
your seat up so I can eat and she said
yes and once the food was taken away
she then reclined her seat again and he
got really angry and started to punch
her seat she said that she called a
stewardess over and she kind of rolled
her eyes at the woman and offered him a
complimentary rum for his for his like
inconvenience give him more alcohol he
said yeah he's a good drinker and once
she started to record he's not as
punching the scene just started kind of
tapping at it the way he is in the video
I think that American Airlines is wrong
in this I think that guy's a [ __ ] and I
think he's also a woman she's also an
older woman or she's a woman a woman so
she's a smaller brain she doesn't know
how she's got a smaller branch but she's
a woman that like how about being a
gentleman you [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] up a shame she should've done
that hitch I thought that both they're
both kind of like douchey both of them I
don't know
would you recline into someone a woman
does that waiting I'm gonna be like if
she's like I'm gonna be like she's got a
reclinable see that's just I got a [ __ ]
in the deal I'm like bad I might say
something I'm not gonna hit her so that
was stupid to you because he's being a
you can't hit it I would [ __ ] you
know what I would do I'd slit his [ __ ]
everybody on the plane and it would be
on him cuz I can't have witnesses and
then I gotta delete her phone and find
out what her first I got to find out
what her passcode is so I can I delete
it from the cloud I'd be annoyed that
like you're giving him friendly you
giving him free rum he's punching him
why is he getting free alcohol sure and
ROM what are you a pirate mom on a plane
I have some rum matey
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]